all right interesting Twitter bait about
valuations are they too high I know they
start up killer tons of data on
incubators and valuations looks like
right now people were complaining at
least on the Twitter about the 15
million-dollar Y Combinator caps are
back yeah I mean this is kind of always
the debate and I you know I think people
people kind of talk past each other in
this debate saying like oh you can't
value invest in startups and I think no
one's saying that so let me make a
different statement and valuations are
too high yeah just because I think it's
a better frame which is round sizes are
too low if you're raising it twenty
million dollars don't raise a million
dollars because you're not gonna
position yourself for success going
forward so I'm planning about your
valuation I'm complaining about your
round size your party round of 1 million
at 20 good luck with that
yeah and the reason is you've now
diluted 5% let's say for the million and
now you've only got a million dollars to
build a 20 million dollar enterprise
value if you don't get to 20 million in
an enterprise value which would be I
don't know what amount of revenue
getting to a Series A I don't know that
it's necessarily a fixed set of
milestones around revenue
often it could just be technology but if
it was an enterprise software company
you'd be looking at a million bucks
to 3 to 3 million bucks of revenue and a
clear market leader at this point if
you're gonna go raise a Series A right
which means you're real tough it's a
high margin and so the question is well
what's your plan B no one ever thinks
about their plan B we're all special
beautiful unicorns but to raise one at
20 you're gonna put together that round
with a bunch of people who are not gonna
haggle with you on price right and I
always think about it is it's it's
infinitely harder to raise a million
bucks in one check than it is to raise
ten hundred K checks from a bunch of
people who aren't gonna be there when
you need that bridge because you're at
750 K revenue all right and so you guys
you've actually built some enterprise
value you've just created a structural
risk in that realm by making dumb
choices that's gonna kill your company
so I think you know the debate ended up
being you know as some of these Twitter
things are a little bit lower
brow than it could have been but I think
shop yeah
right the the you know for the founders
out there I think you want to surround
yourself with people who can help you
think about building a big pie yeah it's
a raise a fair round you know investor
shouldn't be screwing you you shouldn't
be thinking about them in this very
transactional way you've got to put
together a team that's gonna help you
for the long haul yeah and I think
that's not the mindset of many companies
that are in a position to raise whatever
I just say Y Combinator companies are
looking to they've positioned the
investors as the enemy they position
them as adversaries I think and that I
think is the big problem because you get
caught in this trap where you had a
party round and then things don't go
well like you're saying you're at 750 in
revenue you're burning whatever 50k a
month you got a real business but now
who's going to invest at a twenty
million on that business that's proven
he can so fast here's here's what I I'll
give my like outsider II yeah sure very
very occasional amateur hour and angel
investor and you know full-time
entrepreneur markets gonna tell these
folks right if like well I don't even
understand what the debate is because do
I think that that is too high or do I
think that that is ridiculous for
amusement yeah so I'm just not gonna
invest not only what are we even talking
about like just if you want to opt out
then opt out and if you want to be you
know what I would say is probably not
super wise and opt in and maybe you'll
have a good outcome and maybe you won't
I to me I think the real problem is that
there's a lot of inexperienced founders
out there getting some really bad advice
that's exactly right I mean then people
have said hey well this is the market I
think that's right
so to me the market is not the problem
the markets gonna be what it is the
problem is that these founders are doing
things that are just gonna burn two
years of their life right they're gonna
burn two years of their life they're
gonna shut this thing down and they'll
have another shot but it's kind of a
bummer right like I'd rather founders
not burn two years of their life with
completely unforced errors so yeah the
market is what it is and and to be fair
to YC I don't think I don't actually
think that they're you know I don't
think that the advice people are
explicitly getting is right they invest
or just you know they're idiots be
transactional I should think it's like
you look around and everybody else is
raising at these valuations yeah you
feel kind of an ego thing around it
that's definitely the people that
they're trying to set a record they're
like we want to get to 25 you know look
it's really expensive everything is
really expensive everything like from
top to bottom you know these these
prices are not just reflective of the
venture capital market it's reflective
of housing costs and what it costs in
terms of equity to recruit a great
engineer top to bottom everything is
insanely priced right now well but those
should be about round sizes as opposed
to valuation so yeah you need three
million bucks to get to a Series A in
San Francisco that's a little bit nuts
but actually you could do that at a nine
post or a twenty five post right you
just you need more money to get there it
doesn't necessarily imply a larger
valuation and and I think again some of
this is like experience and you know
maybe a little bit of enlightenment and
I'm gonna you know vaguely pat myself on
the back here but I had an opportunity a
few years ago raising around from an
institutional who said just pick
whatever valuation you feel is
reasonable right and they were doing a
few million dollars in the company he's
just bigger valuation and I
intentionally picked something that post
was sub 10 because I didn't want to fall
victim to this trap now granted like you
know the outcome is still yet to be seen
because we're still working on stuff but
you know that's that is just a function
of me having great advisors and having
had experiences so I you know that's why
I say like to me the problem is not what
what is the market going to bear or not
bear I think that that's gonna make
itself very evident very quickly it's
really you know what kinds of advice and
inputs are these founders get it yeah I
think that's right
yeah the other thing that's kind of a
bummer is now there's I guess 200 of
these startups in the demo day and my
understanding is like the top 5% don't
ever go to demo day they close around
and like two or three all the good
rounds are done by demo day every single
one yeah so basically if you're going to
demo day it's like if you don't know who
the worst player at the poker table is
it's you right yeah if you're
automatically dentist new angel'
investor going to demo day and just
popping 250 into like four companies
you're picking the yeah if you believe
it's an outlier based industry or and
those people are good at it you know the
Marc Andreessen so whoever coming in
early
but isn't going to demo day like
investing in crypto funds right I mean
there at this point is there even
anything proprietary about it no its
remnant inventory
I mean remnant inventory the way to look
at yeah you do get lucky sometimes I
mean Bobby get a lot pointed out to me
he said I got a 200 X at a demo day so
great like you can do it but I mean the
number that I would love to see would be
if you indexed the YC batch at their
demo day valuations huh what's the IRR
in that pool right and I suspect that's
very different than Y C's IRR because
their cost basis is literally 10x less
yeah its 1.7 and then you're not you're
seeing some selection bias going into
that pool yeah why doesn't YC release
that information
yeah I mean look they're not obligated
to release their numbers I would love to
see some of that data I think the other
new operate somewhat transparent no no
no not with a list of companies though
I'm not no I'm saying you could
anonymize this yes good this could be
aggregate data that they here's the
thing they which would frankly like help
bolster their case they don't want to
they don't want to stay out there yeah I
mean it would be negative I don't I
believe the IRR would be from to your
point PT from demo day on with those
high valuations would be terrible now if
you could invest in a YC fund at the
investment they're making you would do
that all day long
those companies get to a and do really
great rounds beyond so I mean I think
the way that more savvy investors look
at this is demo day is a nice place to
socialize and you either did the seed
before or you're there to sort of mark
some of these folks to see what it looks
like at the a that's fine I mean yeah
it's a big networking event it's like a
cool party now yeah I did you go this
year it was on the pier I don't go yeah
I don't go to it anymore either I mean I
don't know if I'm invited actually I've
been to if you if you're critical of
them or you critical of anything like if
you even have this conversation we're
having they will literally put you on
the do not fly list and like yeah I
don't feel like a bad relationship with
those folks and I'm very frank about the
things that I think they could be doing
better we've had very constructive
conversations so I
I don't mean to be critical of YC but I
just find demo days to not be very
useful and I used to run a demo day I
know just right you go and you see these
pitches they're all polished it's hard
to really know the good deals are done
before so you know if you want to get
involved in accelerators go early yeah
week to week three we have more these
companies build a relationship with them
is how I think about it